I wanted to do to that tonight class on
openings chess openings and specifically
the idea in the opening is that when
you're started to play chess you just
learn chess and stuff like that that you
somehow you develop this idea of
favorites you have a favorite opening
and this favorite opening stays with you
for your chess career until you decide a
that it's really really really bad or be
that it's really really good you
continue to play it good openings are
basically those openings that are
classical anytime you see white opening
with say e for 1.e4 or one D for the two
most principal opening moves for white
gaining control of the center preparing
to develop a bishop and you respond to
these openings with classical defense
sorry
d5 these classical defense are basically
timeless
they'll be with you for the whole of
your chess career conversely favorites
are those kind of offbeat openings or
defenses that you like because again
when you were a kid you won or they left
such a great impression a nice memory
that you had with a specific opening
defense that you played you continued to
play it but these openings these quote
favorites or offbeat openings as opposed
to classical defenses classical defenses
again they never expire it's like
they're timeless you can play them and
keep on playing classical defenses
you're the hole of your career we're
or is these personal favorites and they
may include for example the Sicilian and
then of course we have one of the
favorite favorite of the favorites the
dragon Sicilian is black I remember as a
kid I loved to play the dragon Sicilian
until I discovered that it was so
popular that had have been analyzed in
great detail and if I didn't keep up the
date on the latest theoretical novelty
well let's say my dragon Sicilian didn't
survive and I like the dragon Cecilia
very much when I was black for the
simple reason the name itself dragon
that's just a cool name you know like I
mean how could you not like the dragon
Sicilian the name it's so cool
and it comes from an ass from an
astronaut
the idea that bees five ponds and the
way they're situated kind of like these
planets this dragon formation from the
planets so the dragon Sicilian was a
real favorite of mine but my favorite
most favorite most favorite and what I'd
like to share with yourselves I mean you
all I assure you you have a favorite
opening a favorite defense whether it be
against 1.e4 or against 1.d4 I had my
own personal favorite against efore was
I like very much to play what is called
the perk defense d6 d4 and how the perk
defense gets its name is after d6 d4
Knight f6 Knight c3 attacking Knight f6
attacking the pawn on e3 Knight c3
defending the pawn on e4 g7 g 6 so this
is the starting position of the perk
defense and I loved fie and shadowing my
bishop putting
my bishop on what we all understand is
the long diagonal so once my bishop goes
to g7 my King goes to g8 I Castle I
create my fortress I just love this
concept of thean shadowing your bishop
on the long diagonal creating a fortress
so that your castle King position was
really strong and it meant that instead
of losing in five ten fifteen moves I
lost it twenty-five thirty forty moves
and that was really good you know like
that I could last so long so I really
liked the idea and doing it with white
as well playing Knight f3 g3 Bishop g2
it was a little bit tougher with black
because of the move f4 this is known as
the Austrian attack or three pawns
attack and with this move white really
is playing for the move e5 and simply to
refute black setup first of all how many
of you played the perk defense not a
single person Wow okay how many of you
play E for and how many of you play the
three pawns or the Austrian attack
against the perk defense
okay so Oh Bishop on g5 on f4 it's a
different setup of course but yes but
this move f4 is the most direct way of
trying to refute the perk defense and
before you criticize me justifiably or
otherwise for hammering the favorite
perk defense of my repertoire do keep in
mind that in 1972 in the World Chess
Championship match between Boris Spassky
white and Bobby Fischer black Bobby
Fischer played the perk defense so you
know kind of felt well if it's good
enough for Bobby and I has got to be
good enough for me okay so again in this
position white has
any many approaches to black setup of
fianchetto Inga's bishop creating a
fortress white can play what is called
the classical system or the Goeller
system with Knight f3 Bishop g7 Bishop
e2 castles castles this is a rather
modest approach by white but white
reasons that he has to Center pawns
abreast of one another and he controls
more space so is it a perfectly
excellent setup for white another setup
for white a far more aggressive one is
the Bishop c4 Bishop g7 Queen e2
variation so the idea behind this
variation is rather than putting the
Queen on e - immediately when the bishop
is on an f1 blocking the bishop first we
bring the bishop out then we bring the
Queen up the idea behind the combination
of these two moves is simply that white
wants to play e5 and then play the movie
six at one time the very big rage there
was a whole theoretical argument about
this line where white sacrifices his
Queen for three pieces that at the same
time loses his entire Center so we can
see that in this moment White has given
up his Queen for three pieces Bishop
Knight Knight Bishop
only one minor piece Queen that the two
Center pawns are gone but this was a
very I remember when this opening was
being debated it was a big question mark
as to who stood better and why White has
very quick development his idea is to
bring his rook to e1 move this night and
still blacks King is caught in the
center very very interesting
and again a different approach from
whites point of view another approach
from whites point of view what we
actually might consider a more modern
approach funnily enough is to play
Bishop III Bishop g7 Queen d2 the idea
here is as direct as it would appear
White's intention is to play Bishop h6
and to trade this fianchetto Bishop
black has spent a good deal of time to
put his bishop on g7 and white reasons
that this bishop will be good so white
plans to play Bishop h6 and trade it off
this is a kind of a modern approach
again there are so many approaches from
White's perspective to the perk defense
that he when you play E for one e4 is
white and your opponent plays the perk
defense you've got to have an approach
in mind well the beautiful part from
blacks point of view that is to say my
point of view is I only had to acquaint
myself with a few systems from white and
I felt very very confident the
chessboard except where this move was
concerned f4 is really really a
challenging one for black to deal with
well how to deal with that I took the
same approach as Bobby Fischer I said
well how Bobby deals with this is that
how I will do all of this and this is
what I call choosing a guide okay
openings are really really tough there
are tons and tons and tons of
possibilities for both sides and trying
on your own to discover which is the
best line of play for a particular
variation is really hard well in this
case we have a really good short trick
we can choose a guide in other words we
take somebody who's a considered expert
in the system and will follow their
advice that's that's our shortcut will
will let our guide make our
determinations for us so against the
move F for Bobby Fischer played Bishop
g7 and again I reasoned what's good
enough for Bobby Fischer is good enough
for me I went Bishop g7 my opponents
would play Knight f3 and I would take
Bobby's approach Bobby's approach was to
play c5 in this position the other
approach was castles so this is a very
standard thing yeah I built a fortress I
put my King there the problem is is that
now this early in the game where my king
is already castled in a sense I've given
my opponent my address now that the king
and now that White knows where white
where blacks King is gone he can focus
and the problem with castles is that
after E 5 97 h4 c5 these were considered
the best moves h5 basically what black
what white is saying is hey I'm just
going to go out here and checkmate your
King I mean and if the game were to
continue for argument's sake would takes
Queen takes knight c6 attacking the
Queen the Queen drops back we'll
understand why in a moment
we can pretty much see that White's idea
is to checkmate oops excuse me checkmate
White's idea is the obvious checkmate on
h7 that cannot be defended by Knight f6
because pawn takes so instead the rook
has to make way for the camel rook moves
check King and this is just a very very
frightening attack because on the next
turn White's intention is to play Bishop
here and trade this very very key
defending piece well I wasn't very happy
about these lines of
and so I wanted to delay castling and it
and for these types of reasons is why I
played the MU c5 okay now here again as
always in all of these openings of so
many choices for both sides to play it's
very very tough but the great Thera
Titian the theoretical the people who
spend their entire lives discovering
theory have determined that d4 take c5
is the best move there are other choices
for white including the move e5 okay
as well as the move Bishop b5 check
first a preliminary check and then after
Bishop d7 e5 many of these lines are
transmitted transpositional they'll go
for a bill they'll end up transposing
and again this whole line of play is
with E 5 well I never feared the move e5
and again the theoreticians determined
in their great wisdom that d4 takes e5
is the most dangerous position for black
so I did a lot of let us say internal
research on this position and I recall
you know like these are the days before
the computers right you know you I'm at
home with my little chess board my peg
in chess board and I've got my notebooks
and I'm sitting there writing all of my
analysis down and you know literally
trying to play both sides ok so I would
play this move if I was black turning
the board or out okay if I was right I
was like this is move you'd like an
amazing thing is I usually won against
myself which is like really hard to do
but
no he wasn't Julia yeah exactly
whichever color happened to prefer at
the time well at the time I was trying
to make this whole scheme with black
work well after this capture it's clear
that blacks position is under great
pressure black does not want to
recapture this pawn because after the
trade of Queens not only do I lose the
right to castle but when white plays d4
a5 which would close off my beautiful
fiance doe Bishop strategically speaking
white is winning black is simply lost so
in this position the move D take c5
would be a strategic disaster of epic
proportions
so that is why everybody and his brother
plays the move Queen a5 and I just love
this move Queen a five on many many
levels the first most important level is
I love my queen is like here's the
flower of my youth the my favorite piece
the strongest piece on the board if I
lost my queen I oftentimes lost the game
so you know my results went hand in
glove with what I was doing with my
queen and I love bringing up my queen
and in this particular case it really
fits with blacks particular setup
because now that the Queen comes out to
a5 the knight on c3 is in an absolute
pin to the King on a1 and what I'm
really want to do is play Knight takes
e4 the pawn on e4 is protected by the
knight but as the knight is in this
absolute pin Knight takes e4 is on
black's agenda and also what's really
really beautiful about Queen a5 followed
by Knight takes e4 is think about the
position from a point of view of harmony
for a moment if it was black smooth
let's say let's give white an
opportunity to make a
Renne this decision and play the move h3
or let's do it even a little bit better
for white let's imagine that he takes
this pawn on d6 well now we would play
Knight takes e4 and just look the knight
on e4 attacks the knight on c3 the
bishop on g7 attacks the knight on c3
and the Queen on a5 attacks the knight
on c3 remarkably Black has only
developed three pieces his Queen his
Knight his Bishop and each and every one
of them are pounding this curse III so
this is what we call harmony baby I mean
everybody's working together so after
the move Queen a5 it's simply not
allowable for black to be able to
capture this pawn on e4 and why of
course defends the pawn on e4 Bishop d3
defending the pawn on e4 now in this
position now is the time to take this
pawn on c5 so Queen takes e5 winning
back the pond it took me I'd oh boy did
I tried so very hard I really wanted
this move Knight takes e4 to work and I
if we were to go to Amsterdam today and
go to my study and to my library where
I've got all the notebooks of my past
when I was a young we could go and I I
you could see my notebook Knight takes
e4 darn it this is a bad move that was
what I wrote in my moment because after
the move Bishop takes e4 Bishop takes c3
at first it all looks so very promising
for black Queen takes c3 not only checks
the White King but looky-looky-looky
it attacks the rook and then I spotted
it this terrible move Bishop d2 - which
defends or blocks the check to the king
but simultaneously now that the bishop
goes in front the Queen defends the rook
and after Queen takes c5 well the
resulting position is one two three one
two I'm a piece down white is winning so
I couldn't make Knight takes e4 work so
I played Queen takes e5 and by the way
this is again the game between Bobby
Fischer Boris Spassky Bobby Fischer now
we come to a new juncture in the game
the first thing is that black can be
very very happy when we were starting we
were starting and I was explaining that
with the pawns on d4 and e4 and f4 White
was building up this huge advance
efore a5 and crushing me off the board
well having traded this pawn on d4 for
this pawn on c7 I've taken a lot of the
punch out of e4 e5 in other words the
pawn on d4 isn't supporting the advance
furthermore now that my queen is on c5
it's proving a little bit of a nuisance
for white that nuisance specifically is
that the Queen on c5 controls the square
G 1 making castles illegal so everybody
including Boris Spassky we haven't come
to what I call the crucial position my
favorite position in my chess opening
Queen e2 so Boris Spassky and everybody
plays the move Queen e2 with a very
simple concept that they want to bring
their Bishop to e3 attack gain a tempo
by attacking the black Queen the black
Queen runs away and then after Bishop e3
castle white
is a lead in development and an
excellent position now really it's like
in all of these grand master games and
I'm talking thousands of chess Grand
Master games games played between
grandmasters everybody including Bobby
Fischer played knight c6 Bishop III
Queen went to a five castles castles and
basically you have the opening more or
less ended still there was more moves
that were played but the the essence of
the opening has been achieved both
people both players of castled and the
development usually I believe that the
game between Bobby Fischer and Boris
Spassky Boris played rook d1 Bishop g4
h3 Bishop takes Queen takes and they
went on from here eventually Bobby drew
with black which was a success he was
leading in the world championship match
at the time and draws brought him closer
to victory so we reached this position
in everybody and I just mean everybody
including Bohr including Bobby Fischer
played knight c6 well I took another
approach this is my novelty this is my
invention and I was very very pleased
with myself trying to Pat myself on the
back as much as possible and I won lots
of games with the strategy that I
developed so instead of playing the move
knight c6 I played the move castles and
again for some reason the powers that be
they frowned upon this move this move
was not precise or not good or whatever
reasons they just didn't like this move
but I love this move and everybody who I
played this position with
would play the move Bishop III which is
very very standard and obvious white
develops his bishop with a gain of time
against my queen and this is where I
started to trick my opponents I played
the move Queen before this was like my
favorite favorite favorite move so
instead of putting my Queen on a5 like
Bobby Fischer and many others my Queen
went to the be for square with the
impudent idea of simply capturing this
pawn on b2 in the words of nickel I'm an
F gift meat upon gift meetable that's
what I want gift me the pause so at this
moment first of all I must say that this
move this idea of castles and Queen
before oftentimes caught my opponents by
surprise and oftentimes their first
reaction was to defend the pawn on b2
with the move rook be one or two castle
can anybody explain to me why both of
those moves would be bad why would the
move rook be one be bad the yeah there's
a trick in the position the trick in the
position is again as we seen the the
knight on c3 is in an absolute pin to
the King on e one strangely enough
suddenly this rook which was supposed to
be the defender of the pawn on b2
becomes vulnerable because of Knight
takes e4 and I can't tell you how many
games I won like Vince it was like
Knight takes e4 Bishop takes e4 the only
way and now Bishop takes c3 check now
first of all the bishop cannot be
captured because the rook would be
hanging in that case and next keep in
mind that this Queen on b4 is
simultaneously attacking this bishop so
I've already won upon with more goods to
flow so route b1 is a terrible move and
it was oftentimes played the next
against me
the next terrible move was castles so
from the point of view of the white
player this makes perfect sense you
defend the pawn on b2 you can gain a
tempo a future with a three but more
importantly you can play e5 and maybe
it's better to be castled on opposite
sides White has an edge in development
it's all going nicely in White's favor
and then I would play Knight takes e4
again and it was sort of like oh well
wait a minute how is that possible that
pawn on e4 is defended by the knight on
c3 as well as the bishop on d3 and you
can't white just win a piece if white
were to play Knight takes e4 then this
my pride and joy this bishop that I see
and shout out so very early it comes to
my rescue and I would play Bishop takes
B to check the king is forced to go into
the line of fire of the Queen and after
I drop back with Bishop c3 check King
has to go to c1 and then Queen B -
checkmate
and it's like please sign my score sheet
I said you know another you know victory
well so it only took the Seattle
community about two years to catch up to
where I was coming from and I was
winning lots of games in accounting my
prized checks before somebody came up
with the correct
for white and and they castled and
essentially this was a kind of a you
know I was double daring and they're
calling my bluff
I said lesson I'm putting my queen on a
vulnerable square where there's I mean I
could easily get trapped some jeopardy
for me but I insist that I want to take
the pawn on b2 and this move castle says
are you serious or are you bluffing
right I mean I don't know I'm serious I
want to take this pawn on b2 so I would
take this pawn on b2 and again I want to
repeat myself by saying this was a
favorite position of mine and I reached
it quite often in many of my games so
after the move Queen takes b2
well if you're not paying attention I'm
going to take your knight and I'll win
again yay so do something and the white
player would play the move Knight d5 and
that's really doing something that's
doing a lot because now I had I faced
two completely separate and devastating
threats the first threat I face is well
this night on loops excuse me this night
on b5 is threatening to come to c7 where
my trap route will be captured so I'm
threatened with the loss of my rook
furthermore I'm threatened with the loss
of my queen for example let's suggest I
play a silly move I'm just going to play
a silly move in other words I play this
move with the idea I'm going to lose my
rook you go here I'll go here with my
bishop you take my rook I'll take your
knight
so in other words I accept the loss of
my rook well that's one thing the
problem is I'm actually being faced with
a loss of my queen so the move rook F 1
b1 traps my queen my queen has no square
to go it can't take the pawn on c2 it
can't take the pawn on a2 it can't go to
a3 the night covers a3 and all of these
squares are covered or occupied so I'm
sure that the first time somebody played
the move Knight b5 against me they were
like okay that takes care of you
now it's time for you to sign my score
sheet okay so but I had seen much much
further ahead than just this position I
had it in my mind that I had a move that
addressed both threats can anybody
suggest a move for black which address
this was both France Julian 98 very very
very good okay so with the move Knight
b5 the threat was to go to Knight c7 so
with the move Knight e8 I protect the c7
square to begin with so I address one
threat and the second thing that I do is
I create a square a retreat square for
my Queen to go to f6 now can anybody
suggest and move for white how how could
white take advantage or what should Y do
at the moment basically what I've done
is in broad daylight I stole upon I
stole upon I took this pawn on B to keep
in mind that this diagonal maybe this
rook on a1 is vulnerable
maybe I might take the rook if nothing
else my intention is maybe to retreat my
Queen all the way back home and I'm
going to stay upon
head or to simply develop my pieces with
knight c6 Bishop here and then one day
I'll move this night away and okay
you've got to decide so any ideas for
white how could white continue so Aoife
there you go and a lot of my opponents
played the movie for e5 which is very
very suggestive this move e4 e5 on
several levels the first and most
obvious is that okay with the move e5
you're threatening to trap my queen with
the move e5 you've closed off my
beautiful Bishop on the long diagonal
it's very tragic of course and so if you
think about it more or less from the
start when white has pawns on d4 and e4
and F for his entire emphasis had been
to play the move e5 so on three levels
the move e5 is suggestive you close the
Bishop it's what you wanted to do and
you threaten to trap the Queen wow
that's so cool I mean you know I mean it
just works so well from White's point of
view Y has to be the one
now padding them themselves on the
shoulder for they're under their true
chess understanding and you know
everything else because it all just it
is all beautifully fits you know it just
God it makes the best of the best sense
but you know I and and and this is how
the whole thing about chess and one of
the things that was so very attractive
to me about chess chess is a battle of
ideas okay just because I beat you in
chess or you beat me doesn't make you
smarter or me smarter than you it just
means that the ID
yeah that I had was better than yours
okay so in this position after the movie
five White's very full of himself very
proud but I take another point of view I
go gosh I'm so happy you played the
movie five well why should I be happy
that you played the movie if I well in
the first case it cost you a tempo isn't
that correct I mean you play the movie
five and now it's my turn
and I can get my Queen out of Dodge my
queen it you're threatening to trap me
with your rook this move rook f1b one
threatens to trap my queen so I'll
simply move away with my queen so in
other words I'll dance happily into
happily away so with the move Queen
before in the first place I get my queen
ah Dahak
I now have squares like Queen a5 to
retreat to I have ideas of just
developing my knight developing my
bishop and here's the point here's the
real real real point you played the
movie 45 with evil intentions but they
were good reasons for playing the movie
five but on another from another
perspective when you played the movie
five you put these two pawns in tension
with one another correct the d6 pawn is
attacking the e5 pawn just as the e5
pawn is attacking the d6 pawn well the
other good thing about this tension from
blacks point of view is whenever this
tension gets resolved this Bishop starts
to look real good remember my pride and
joy very very start of the whole lecture
how I love to fianchetto my dish ap-- so
I'm really looking forward to an
opportunity that once this tension is
resolved that my Bishop is going to have
a really excellent
Vista view of the game now anybody would
like to make a suggestion as to what
white should do at the moment he's upon
now and he's trying to punish me for my
impudence and grabbing this pawn White's
development by the way is simply
excellent one two three four five six
seven eight nine pretty good one two
three four five
hold on one two three four five six
seven so White's ahead and development
that he's behind in material by a pawn
and in the meantime all black is trying
to do is catch up with development by
playing moves like Knight c6 Bishop g4
and trying to resolve this tension
favorably of course for the second
player its suggestion for white rook a
b1 and understand which is a tempo of
course with ideas like playing f4 has
been played f4 ok so first of all
developing a piece in this case a rook
with tempo against the Queen that's very
attractive and you secondly you
suggested the idea that you would like
to follow up with the move f4 f5 and who
knows like sac blacks King on the
kingside and it's all very good so after
the move rook a b1 in fact I simply
don't have well I do have a little bit
of a choice I could go here but that
doesn't make much sense to me let me
instead play the move Queen a5 which is
a lot more logical with my Queen on a5
remember how I said a new battle has
flared over the control of the e5 pawn
10
so the Queen on a5 while at the moment
doesn't directly attack the pawn on e5
there's an opportunity in the future
that when this night is pushed or shoved
or moved backwards after the move a six
the Queen could influence this pawn and
by the way the Queen on a5 does protect
the square c7 which means that this
burden that the knight has at the moment
of defending this square is shared in
other words the knight can move and
finally with the move Queen a5 I'm
threatening not immediately but one day
maybe you know that's another poll yay
okay so after the move rook b1 would you
like to proceed f5 at the moment the
move f5 in the immediacy doesn't seem
very attractive to me in the first place
is Bishop on c8 could capture this pawn
but I'm more eager to capture this pawn
and in case you were to trade I would
recapture and that moment I stand two
pawns to the good and I don't see any
problem for black as soon as I play
knight c6 and maybe Bishop to g4 I'm
doing pretty okay I mean you know things
are definitely not going in White's
favor
so after rook e1 Queen a5 how can white
continue
in truth at this moment white is already
in deep trouble
in whites in deep trouble he won't be
able to prove a compensation my king is
actually quite safe and it's very clear
as soon as I play knight c6 and capture
or if you capture this pawn and I trade
Knights you simply do not have
sufficient compensation for the pawn so
you actually have to go back one move
because this very attractive move rook
a1 b1 which was played against me by a
number of opponents really doesn't cut
the mustard okay and the very best move
and it took me a while to find it for
white because I actually really like
blacks position with white Julian eat XD
6 e takes d6 not very convincing new
variation Edie Edie not very convincing
how exactly White's supposed to follow
up knight c6 Bishop e6 knight in the
first place do keep in mind there's a
tempo in the second place do keep in
mind that after night c6
a6 you're not even a hundred percent
sure that the knight will ever get out
pardon me tonight take Knight takes a
seven here that's exactly right
in fact it actually works best in
White's favor not to resolve this
tension instantly it takes I didn't test
this line but one one idea that black
has is imagine I were to play Knight
takes even for just a second new
variation Knight takes DC
and imagine you were to play Knight c7
yep so now imagine that I play Bishop g4
and now imagine you took my rook and
imagine whoo do I have to play no I I'm
trying to trap the night and play knight
c6 and rook takes so I sacrifice an
exchange but I don't think that that I
never tested that I just thought of that
as a possible idea
another possibility is when you take
this pawn on d6 excuse me some stranger
I could play the move knight c6 and
again we could put in this particular
case for example after rupee one now in
this case it's better
Queeny 7 you could take Queen a5 you
could take on e7 I can take bishop here
and again you're winning this exchange
right this you're going to take one of
the rooks in this case the rook on the
f8 so after takes on these boots should
do huh where where's the captures on d6
there it is all right after the takes on
d6 take on d6
now you have to decide how you want to
continue playing Knight takes a 7 right
okay so Knight takes a 7 then because
you've made you resolve this tension it
means I can take your rook okay and
you'll take my bishop and I will develop
and here it's a kind of a funny thing
but you know it's it's that whole
fortress thing and one of the reasons I
like the fortress is so much I have lost
a very
the important palace guard this bishop
on g7 but in some cases my knight is
actually working on g7 pretty good
because I could jump in the near future
to the f5 square so White has cost
himself in exchange and I don't think
that there's sufficient compensation
it's a possibility but I think it's
easier to play black so the actual move
that the yes Julian please
okay let's do that again sorry II takes
d 6e take Boop sorry route he takes d6
before you you want to toss in c3 okay
this is a nice idea and again you know
one of the things again one of the
things that's so very very attractive to
me about chess is this battle of ideas
and I love these types of moves you
flick in the little c3 move you know you
gain the tempo against the Queen you
block the bishop and later you play
Knight a7 but that's what the battle of
ideas is all about well I'm not going to
let you take the pawn 87 anymore you
know your that my clean great I'll move
it with Queen a5 and my rook I've got a
seven protected well enough
Black's doing fine again we can easily
imagine that the night may jump out that
the bishop comes out and pawn up and
maybe the some these split pawns are a
more a source of weakness than strength
so we go back to this position and my
opponents finally and at long last and
it took him about two years they came up
with a really really good move they
would play Knight takes a seven so first
of all they win the pawn back okay and
secondly I still haven't fully rescued
my queen in some cases for example after
rook be one Queen a5 I may have to be
mindful of rook b5 but what the real
idea was was to crash through after
knight c6 Knight takes rook takes rook
here oops
how did that happen yeah yeah I think
wow yeah man that really had something
going for that was I that wasn't
kryptonite was something that was a
super rook so their idea was to crash
through on to b7 so my queen for example
with step backwards as we've seen before
and then after rook takes pawn takes
pawn takes there they're suggesting that
I could take but then after rook takes
White forces are at long last
coordinating so this move Knight takes a
seven was really a bit of an annoyance
for me because it was really combined
with the idea that you want to take this
Bishop which exposes this pawn on b7
okay
makes perfect sense right this beautiful
beautiful flow of logic and you
understand but then at the same time you
go lay them in it what is white doing
I mean he's playing Knight c3 Knight d5
Knight takes a seven you know I you know
you spent three moves winning my pawn on
a7 I mean this is genius and the Knights
let's say let's just imagine for a
briefest of moments the knight actually
doesn't capture my bishop on c8 let's
say my bishop actually wanders away
let's say Bishop to g4 then after a move
like rook B 1 followed by rook takes a
set a rook takes b7 well your Knights
still on the stupid square a7 like
that's supposedly good for you being on
that square a7 so a lot of questions
kind of come into your mind and one of
the questions that came into my mind
when will let me turn it back to
yourselves for a moment so if you were
black in this position and it's it's a
weird position right I mean you know
like it you've been the knight somehow
has been chased to a hospital on e8
but on the other hand like this rook on
a eight
thanks to this Knight capturing the pawn
you've developed my rook on a eight for
me right now my works on like a half
open file and all I really got to do is
a solve certain development problem and
then things may turn in my favor so for
example uh suggestions for black I'm
looking for two suggestions toss out a
good move if you see one don't worry
pardon
Bishop e6 is an excellent first
suggestion second one Queen Ava well be
careful that is a bishop you know so
knight c6 Knight takes rook takes rook
be one Queen a5 rook b7 was a very our
very first variation I'll show the
second move that I was thinking first of
all the first move that was suggested
was Bishop e6 a very very very
reasonable move in the first place
the knight attacks your Bishop move the
damn bishop you're right I mean isn't
that what your mom's told you you know
like son if they attack you run away
okay it works for me
and not only are you developing your
bishop and you're running away but hello
you know you know you're kind of looking
at this pawn and then maybe you know one
day you will take it so Bishop e6 is a
very reasonable move again I talked
about the conflict between the d6 and
ePHI pawns also extremely logical move
would be for example Bishop g4 so in
this case after moves like rook e1 Queen
a5 rook takes b7 one idea that black
might have is to capture this pawn twice
with pawn takes pawn takes Bishop takes
relying upon the fact that this knight
on f3 is a pen and it's a kind of a
messy messy variation well one of the
things that how many are you are you
familiar with the concept of clumsy rook
you ever heard concept clumsy rook okay
it's interesting
clumsy rook rooks are so easy to
understand they go left right up down
the problem everybody should understand
their rooks but the reality is is that
literally players who were below master
chess master level really have a problem
understanding rooks and you have what is
called a clumsy rook syndrome where
players really don't use the rooks very
well well I had clumsy rooks syndrome
okay I really played poorly with my
rooks so I oftentimes like to sacrifice
them yeah makes perfect sense you lose
your rook you don't have to worry about
how to play with it right yeah baby yeah
well I wanted to get a little bit more
than a pun so I often like to sacrifice
my rook and this was the other variation
I was really hoping to ask it's it's
like from a material point of view you
know what are you doing you're
sacrificing exchange you're giving up a
rook of 5/4 Knight of three however
consider the following idea after Bishop
takes rook on a 796 first of all I'm
gaining a tempo very important my knight
that was on pre returns a favor to
attack the bishop on a7 so I gain a
tempo secondly consider the idea that
the pawn on f4 is hanging so that if I
could capture that pawn this guy would
lose its key support and finally with
the knight on c6 I'm attacking the pawn
on e5 so for these reasons my opponents
would often play against me the move
Bishop e3 first of all you know
retreating that the the bishop was a
track and defending the pawn on f4 and
now you have to make an assessment what
we simply call you have to make a
judgment call
who stands better and why
like what is it that you like about
whites position what is it that you like
about blacks position so the first thing
is we do a material count one two three
four five one two three four okay
so black has a pawn for an exchange upon
a night now we have to look a little bit
deeper than the than the four versus the
five and just say a pond because these
ponds are also split so they're really
not that great and what we find over
here on the other hand is we have a four
versus two majority and the majority
simply excellent finally if we have our
rights once this night goes to d6 the
night will be terrific on d6 it'll be
defending the pawn on b7 or we defend
and in in a dreamlike world a dreamlike
fantasy this night will either be traded
for the bishop or for the night and then
e 5 fi d 4 F 4 and the and the majority
goes so this was a position that I put a
lot of energy in and I really really
studied it it became a favorite position
of mine and I won a lot of victories
from it at the same time what's very
interesting today is chess engines chess
engines have become really really really
strong and at the time I assess this
position as unclear worth playing
I enjoyed blacks position the chess
engines today say no this is a good
position for white and yet it's still a
position I would like to play